news now on this Gloomy gray day still
no sign of Mojave Max's emergence but
there's been some movement captured on
the camera see on the left side of your
screen there he had a little visitor
Apparently one of his roommates they did
a little scan though and they said oh no
that's not Max it's his roommate and
then she scurried back into their little
girl roommate so we're still waiting for
him to emerge I wonder if his roommate
has a name though I mean you have mac
maybe Maxine right I went there and I
was like oh there's Mojave Max and there
was a sign it was some other tortoise I
was yeah well hopefully this is a sign
of spring to come spring is actually
just a few days away on the 20th